hello and welcome to this video joke
face is the opponent joke face pretty
new account I it's got tons of five
minute and one had one game against
women okay so c6 okay i don'ts like
defies just play you for to prevent it
coochhie he five okay
just the point of the Center for we
should be three isn't the Queen on h5
and so what exposed ok now I can
theoretically speaking take the pawn on
d6 should i do that it's probably the
kind of move that the computer just
mercilessly plays yeah actually think it
is just a blunder isn't it or is he
having enough compensation there we
should be six and really a bit difficult
to believe
can also play Queen a3 immediately yeah
let's do it push the night back probably
to c7 and then develop him
soon ok I'm going to play against the
Queen yeah I'm threatening g4 now
winning the green okay yeah we'll check
the night now he won't seek the night
wow so okay then we'll just play this
ending two points up
check
yeah it takes I guess
hmm okay maybe that wasn't technically
the cleanest way of doing it they're
definitely wasn't rock t4 was a lot
stronger try to double them
okay I could have probably had this a
little bit easier
so what's the easiest way to windows
before King c3 is actually I will be
three check
it's slightly annoying and maybe I
should do it with those pawns
h4 takes King edge three check up take a
form
I could have had this lot easier mmm
time learning about that bloody move
it's really a shame if this voltage was
really bad technical play it still wins
but it was far more complicated than
necessary check
check check check 20 seconds bloody hell
check
check check check check we've been very
quick with the rock check checkmate wow
that was very bad technical plane okay
so he went for this for this kind of
play I don't believe in that very much I
think the queen is not well placed
especially not with the night only to ya
if 5v5 he probably should take on 25 now
I just think this doesn't work I can't
grab this that's more or less winning
for wine could have taken a second porn
but this is very convincing I think now
here and yeah an Audi forum and we get
to this and now I should I should just
be more precise i took this Queen 96 I
went back check and then the check so
okay I don't have to take maybe I should
just I should simply avoid the capture
it makes it a little bit tricky already
a little bit okay you should see five is
stronger I just actually are they
oh wow again check what a what an
idiotic play it already it looked
strange share with this hanging bishop
ok now ok I've 95 ah it's also much
easier because there's s-97 ok yeah yeah
I mean he is sort of f5 him I just up to
48 ok two points white should win MIT is
fairly active and it was really weird so
I mean taking already is may be
questionable I thought that this should
still be somewhat easy wet around here I
cannot got cold feet I wasn't totally
sure that this wins I chose this and he
threatening this the engine gives each
form check yeah this is probably better
I actually think that I didn't spoil it
but it just felt extremely yeah Charlie
even like unless chattering accomplish
anything chat here check why twins
fairly easily yeah I don't know maybe it
wasn't all that terrible but I would
look NAT G for which was bad if you
could have done that I would have yeah
all my advantage
would have been lost in this one move
okay thanks for watching